We can generalize compaction in the following way--compact is an operation that
allocates exactly 1 item in the output for each true input and 0 items in the output for each false input.
This is useful, of course, in compact as a really common operation.
But more generally we can do a compact-like operation
where the number of output items can be computed dynamically for each input item.
Let me offer a graphics example to show why this might be useful.
The input to most real time computer graphics pipelines is a set of triangles.
Some of these triangles might appear on the screen and some might not.
And so we generally test to see if each triangle is visible or not,
before we pass it down the pipeline for later processing.
This is a compact operation--we compact an input stream of triangles, some of which are visible
and some are not, into a smaller output stream where all triangles in the output stream are visible.
And we know how to do this with compact. Now, here's the more complicated problem.
What if a triangle intersects the boundary of the screen or window,
for example this triangle here, or this triangle here?
In this case we apply an operation called clipping,
where we cut the triangle with the boundary, and then triangulate the resulting shape.
So for this triangle, for instance, we're going to convert it to this triangle right here.
This triangle has left behind a trapezoid, and so we only want to deal with triangles.
So instead we triangulate this trapezoid and send 2 triangles down the pipe.
Now we have a situation where we input a set of triangles,
and each triangle can produce 0, 1, or possibly many output triangles.
And we want to output the resulting triangles in a dense array.
Here's a good geometry quiz question for you that has really nothing to do with the course material,
but it's a pretty cool question nevertheless.
What is the maximum number of triangles that can result from clipping a triangle with a rectangle?